ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
another for honor video here it is
Thursday we have a devastating recap and
I have exciting news to bring you about
a new Halloween event that's gonna be
starting actually today and will be
ending November 2nd for for honor so
let's not waste any time let's get
started so it is a Halloween event and
it's gonna be going from like I said
October 19 to November 2nd and it will
be called the Feast of the overworld
it's gonna have a new atmosphere limited
time free cosmetic loot spooktacular
game mode event bone-chilling weekly
content and themed event orders for the
spooky atmosphere there's going to be
themed music that is revolving around
Halloween type stuff skeletons are not
gonna be replacing minions I'm not
entirely sure if that's going to be in
every mode within minions or if it's for
the new weekly game mode we'll get to
that in a bit and the mysterion new
mysterious orders there's also going to
be free lootable content which is the
battle outfit called grasping death and
the cut and the ornament held driver as
well as the effect called pull under now
these are going to be free lootable
except the effects the ornament and the
outfits are going to be free lootable
that you can get and obtain after every
match except duel Pete duel versus AI
bots you can get it from any match and
it's random and these rewards will be
for random heroes as well it is not
based on the play based on the hero you
play it is based around every single
hero they're only going to be lootable
during this event so get them while you
can but if you get them you can keep
them for the rest of your time playing
for honor there's also a little video
that they showed showing off some of
these so I will show that to you guys
right now
[Music]
[Music]
so that was the those are the effects I
really really enjoyed the effects it
looks really cool to me I'm gonna
definitely have to pick that up but
moving on we have a new spooktacular
game mode called the endless March it is
going to be a four view for Dominion
game and the minions are going to be
skeletons now and they do about 14
damage per hit which is about the same I
believe as conch
so conch is basically getting nerfed
down to a skeleton again the only two
sources of hard points which is points
that won't go away are minions we are
the minions which are the skeletons they
will be three points and players are
going to be 15 points capturing zones a
and B only give you soft points of
two-hundred lane control does not give
you any hard or soft points 1,000 points
to break the team and then once that is
over you kill the enemy team in it's
game over it's like normal Dominion but
with this a little bit of a twist now
for the new weekly content for this for
week one it's going to be masks outfits
that whole spiel that we had with the
whole masks in the tab of the outfit
section we have that now there are three
miniature photos shown here of what they
look like for the samurai for the Viking
and for the Knights the Knights have
this little like spooky kind of skull
the Vikings are doing some little voodoo
magic and the samurai have some Japanese
demon on their head week week two is
going to be a new emo it's called howl
of the moon basically you're gonna be
emoting and then there's this wolf
that's going to be shouting above you
it's going to have sound effect and all
that cool stuff
as for the themed event orders this
week's is going to be slayer event which
is as a community perform as many player
takedowns as you can in any type of
match PvP or PvE I the reward will be
2,000 steel it is going to be happening
this weekend just like every event order
is and the second one we don't actually
know there was a question mark so we'll
probably get to know that next week and
once again I'll keep you all informed on
that and that's about it for this entire
event once again to recap there's going
to be some new armor some new minions
free lootable content that you will get
to keep if you do
get those ornaments and such and a lot
of cool things I'm very glad for Honor's
finally getting its first real event so
I'm very very excited for this and that
was basically the end of the video guys
it was a shorter dev stream it was about
45 minutes long but the whole thing was
dedicated to this event so I'm very glad
and i just wanna i want to share a photo
real quick if none of you caught the dev
stream three devs worm on damien and
eric the community developer all thought
to all fault to bring out outfits and
I've been sitting here recording this
and it's been about two and a half hours
and I still can't stop laughing at
Damien's Luigi outfit it's just so
perfect either way guys let me guys let
me know what you guys think about this
event or if you've even played it what
do you guys think about it at the moment
anything that has to do with this event
I'd love to know what you guys have to
say but with that being said that is the
end of the video guys if you did enjoy
the video hit that like button
I really does help me out if you're new
to this channel subscribe for more all
for honor news and leaks and anything
that comes up regarding the game I'll
always be posting you guys keeping you
all posted my two most recent videos are
gonna be popping up on screen if you
guys dismiss those they're also more dev
stream recaps and then with that guys I
hope you have a great rest of your week
and weekend and I'll see you all later
and peace out